every squad has one person with a weird
setup but rebinding wasd or getting
addicted to a weird kind of mouse or
keyboard is a lot more understandable
than well this Fanatics faster is a
Dutch CS GoPro who just finished top 8
at the Rio major and his settings aren't
just confusing they might make you sick
his left hand is here which doesn't give
him a forward key because he uses right
click to move forward his right click
but that's not even the weirdest part
because fasher's Mouse look is inverting
it's inverted
but why well as faster explained he
grinded the out of flight
simulators because of his dad which
makes sense imagine trying to throw a
smoke when your controls feel like
you're flying a helicopter in
Battlefield let's just get this guy some
shades in a flight stick and complete
the transformation